well it's subject I've been interested
in for a long time what inspired me was
a conversation with my daughter during
the summer of two thousand and six when
the war in Lebanon was going on with
Israel and I started trying to explain
itchy we realized there wasn't what
there wasn't a simple explanation of
what was going on it wasn't just about
Israel and Lebanon or his Balor it was
relevant to Syria how was it relevant to
what was going on with Iran and its
nuclear program did it fitted at all
with with events in Iraq so it seemed to
me that there was a need to talk about
issues from that part of the world in a
connected way I've been wanting to write
something that dealt with contemporary
conflicts a history for some time but I
haven't decided to focus specifically on
the Middle East because i'm not
particularly a Middle Eastern specialist
as such I decided that the way to do it
was through the United States because
though they were Brit I always been
interested in American politics and
written quite a bit about American
politics so that was why I sort of took
the solid
it's a good question because I think a
lot of Americans wish to look forward a
minute of the forward-looking people and
the past which is full of
disappointments and irritations
something you may wish to consign to
historians and let them get on with it
also I think November the September the
11th so I think September the 11th had
appeared a sort of a punctuation point
you know that almost history started and
knew that it was a new era and therefore
the continuities with the previous era
tended to get forgotten you discussions
with senior Americans I would often find
that you know isn't there explain to me
how the country had changed how
attitudes have changed how Americans
would have repented of things different
to how they were prepared to do things
before and I understand that but I think
it's always a shame to lose the real
context of history because the events
that we're dealing with now to me can
only be properly understood if you go
back to at least they're relatively
recent origins you know sometimes you
can go into their very historic well I
think the first US air I don't consider
myself to be a Middle Eastern specialist
to certainly it's an important
qualification and therefore the way I've
tended to look at it is to try to make
sense of the original conflicts going on
so there are a number of big histories
of the Middle East or of the Arab world
by programming people like this but I
think be wrong to say that any of those
particularly influenced me a lot my
approach when I'm writing something like
this it sort of Justice Osieck myself in
whatever I can find I think if you're
not going to do archive bakes research
which I've done but archive based
research requires you to get really into
the detail of particular policies and
work your way through the bureaucracy
and the processes and so on if you're
doing something as broad brush as I as I
never
had to do in this I think you really
need to get not only a good grip of the
secondary material but the memoirs of
the different presidents and so on I'm
looking back and I'm really thought
about it until you posed the question
actually a lot of what I was reading
will books about the American process
rather than the Middle East itself at
every obviously to make sense of what's
going on in Lebanon you had no there's a
number of books about Lebanon but for
what I was trying to do was really to
try to understand it through the
American through Americanized through
the filter so I say Tom Friedman's book
I found particularly good because it
both had the history of the Lebanon
conflict of the 80s but also a
particular impact it was making on him
as an American is a Jew as a journalist
trying to make sense of the conflict as
a time and I think that was always part
of what I've been trying to do in this